katie ledecky joins us now there she is
from california good morning to you
katie ledecky you are really the true
golden girl that's who you are you know
that just you know that jill scott song
living my life like it's golden living
my life that ought to be your theme song
katie ledecky got it there we go well
i've got my got my golds here to show
you
listen i would imagine it never gets old
winning a goal winning a gold medal but
did this one feel different considering
the circumstances of this olympics to
you
i think so you know we all worked an
extra year for these games and just to
be there was so much fun and such a
great feeling to be with team usa and to
be with athletes from all over the world
at the highest stage and i just tried to
enjoy it and soak in every moment and i
felt like i did a pretty good job of
that you did you did a great job at that
katie we had we had caleb dressle here
at the table the other day who told us
that uh competing at the olympics was
like a week of hell in his words
but you've said that that you just get
so much joy in the pool how was this
week for you
i enjoyed it i think
we all had very busy schedules and well
i had a very busy schedule caleb had a
busy schedule but i tried to just go one
race at a time and i felt like that that
helped me
get through the week and and really
enjoy it and i tried to just wake up
each day with a great mindset and with
the the belief that i could could do
what i i came there to do and
just just take care of business and
enjoy being with my teammates you've
said you spent more time in a swimsuit
than sleeping so let's talk about that
waking up how much sleep are you getting
i was probably getting about six hours a
night and i was probably in a swimsuit
about six hours a day during during
my week racing in tokyo so yeah it was a
very busy week i swam 6 200 meters of
racing so it was my program
with the addition of the 1500 free so
it was it was a lot but as i said i i
enjoyed it i enjoyed the challenge and
really just tried to embrace being there
well it was fun watching you but this is
what i thought was very interesting we
were talking about this before you came
on that the 1500 meter race that you won
in goal is nearly a mile a mile it's
nearly a mile swimming you know katie i
can walk and run
it takes me 14 minutes and 39 seconds
can you top that so how do you mentally
and physically prepare to do this i i
marvel that you can do that
well thank you it it takes a lot of hard
work and i've loved the distance events
from a very young age and i feel like
i've just
built up confidence in in that race and
i know how to swim it and i just kept
reminding myself that and felt like i
could could get the job done as i said
you've said you listen to certain music
sometimes i i'm pretty focused on my
race right before and i settle into a
good rhythm uh actually during my 1500
free i was actually thinking of my
family quite a bit during the race which
really helped me through and and really
helped me get my hand to the wall first
yeah you've said when you want to think
about something positive you think about
your grandparents why are your
grandparents
they're the the four toughest people i
know i i still have my two grandmothers
um that are alive and i'm really excited
to go show them the medals when i i get
the chance this month and
uh they just bring a smile to my face
and sometimes that's that's all you need
have a great one katie you've this was
your third olympics but you're already
thinking about your fourth
you're looking forward to that
i am i i really hope i have the
opportunity to represent team usa in
paris and i know i kind of want to just
let this
uh kind of sink in first but i know in
the next couple months i'll be back to
work and back with some new goals for
2024. all right so that's 2024. 2028
is los angeles you want to do that
i i don't know yet i'm not going to
commit to that but i think it'd be so
amazing to compete on home soil so any
athlete that gets the opportunity to do
that is just going to really experience
an incredible olympics and whether i'm
competing or in the stands i know i'll
be there in l.a in 2028. i'll promise
you that katie simone bile sparked a lot
of conversation about mental health i'm
wondering what you all talked about as
athletes what was the conversation and
did you notice a shift in the
conversation about mental health and
athletes in preparing
i think we have really noticed a shift
over the last several years and i just
completed my degree in psychology at
stanford this past year and it's a
really important conversation and i'm
really proud of simone and i'm also
proud of some of my swimming teammates
allison schmidt and michael phelps who
have really led the way as well in this
conversation and
i think we're all just more comfortable
talking about it and and talking about
our feelings with each other and
with the world and i think it's really
going to help a lot of people uh what
what everyone is talking about these
days well katie congratulations on
another amazing olympics we appreciate
you joining us this morning
thanks so much yeah we love watching you
we love watching you rava go usa